I have bone on bone on the left hip, which seems to be getting more restrictive and painful with time.
Be considering hip replacement surgery, my ecologist suggests that no surgeon will touch me given the colorectal cancer.
I've not talked to any surgeons for that reason, but I'm thinking it might anyhow.
Cutter split a protocol seems to be proceeding slowly but fine.
Also, I am not doing any alopathic standards of care, hopefully will not be too.
So it may be a while more my goal of dissolving the tumor is reached, not sure the hip situation can wait, but also concerned with what might be going might be wrong.
I tried supplements to rebuild the cartilage, thoughts on suggestions on the situation.
So, yeah, but you have bone on bone on a in a joint that is certainly a major issue and you're right, your ecologist is probably speaking from experience and saying that the surgeons are not going to want to deal with somebody who has active cancer.
Because they don't know what is going on with possible metastasis to the area, they're not going to do a hip replacement surgery for those kind of risks.
There may be bone loss, there may be, you know, comorbidities to the cancer itself that could put you at greater risk.
Of the possibility that somebody asked this question about using roll on therapy, which is injection.
I think it's like a saline type solution into a joint, I believe it's really only done in the, the D and the hip.
But there may be a practitioner that does that, maybe you already investigated that and they won't touch you either, but that seems like it's not going to be a contract indicative injection for cancer patients.
I think would have anything to do with making anybody's cancer worse even if they're less cancer in there.
So, I will look at that.
Yeah, it's, it's a difficult, it's a difficult thing that if you're taking different, if you're taking supplements, the first supplement you think of as could threaten and if you've done that kind of stuff, I mean, if you're bold on bold, it's not going to help that much.
Yeah, I didn't wish I had a better answer for you on, you know, they, you know, there's cancer patients that have metastasis to the bold and they have bold loss and a fracture in the bold and they still do surgery on that to put it a rod or something like that.
Yeah, I would think you would be able to find a surgery that would still go ahead with surgery.
I would investigate it if I were you at least talk to somebody if you have confidence in them, maybe you want to be bold.